[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Hello and welcome
to the Android Fireside Chats.
We have a lot of
content today, we're
going to get through
that first and see if we
can get to the questions next.
If we could get
to the next slide.
I guess we're ready
for some questions.
So we do actually have one
question to start it off,
if we can go to
that one as well.
So someone asked online
on the Twitter thread,
why is it called a fireside
chat if there is no fire?
I thought this was a
pretty good question.
So the answer to that would be--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So warm yourselves by the fire.
We're going to ask
some questions.
You're going to
ask some questions.
We're going to try to
answer those questions.
So we pre-rolled some
questions online.
It was interesting to see what
people were thinking online.
So we have some of those, we'll
interweave those questions
with questions
from the audience.
I will show you how
that works in a second.
First, let's
introduce the panel.
I'm Chet Haase,
Android Toolkit team.
DAVE BURKE: Dave Burke, I
get blamed for most things.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON:
Steph Cuthbertson, I
work on the
developer experience.
ROMAIN GUY: Romain Guy, I work
on the graphics in Kotlin.
AURASH MAHBOD: Aurash, I work
on Play and Instant apps.
DIANNE HACKBORN:
Dianne Hackborn, I
manage the framework team.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
I'm Xavier Ducrohet
I work on the tools team.
CHET HAASE: We have also
a bunch of other people
from the engineering team
to my stage right here.
So if one of these
people can't answer it,
then maybe one of the
people in the audience
can't answer it either.
So let me show you how
this is going to work.
We have a couple of
questions to kick it off
and then we'll kick it out
to the audience from there.
So first of all, what's
an exciting feature
that you're working on
for the next release?
Romain, do you want
to take that one?
ROMAIN GUY: No, I don't.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: OK, that's a really
good example to keep in mind.
We do not answer questions
about future development, kind
of a policy thing that we have.
I would say 90% of
the questions that I
got in the Twitter
thread when I asked
were about future developments.
So that makes it easy, we
don't have to answer those.
DAVE BURKE: This is
going really well.
CHET HAASE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we'll be done in
the next two minutes.
All right, let's ask
a more real question.
I'll toss this to Romain again.
Will Android
architecture components
be a de facto
architecture choice
with continuous Google support?
That's like continuous
builds except for support.
ROMAIN GUY: So very
long answer, yes.
More seriously, we listened.
You were asking us to have an
opinion about the archetecture.
For many years, we
did not have one.
You could do
whatever you wanted.
You can still do
whatever you want,
but we have a solution
that's our solution.
We're going to support it.
We have tooling, we have more
and more libraries around it,
we have documentation,
tons of talks.
So if you like it
or if you don't even
know what architecture you
want to use, go with that one.
CHET HAASE: So there you go.
That's an example.
In fact, it was a real question
and kind of a real answer
as well.
I would invite everybody in
the audience to ask a question.
There are two
microphones down here.
We were curious
how long it would
take people to get
to the microphones,
so it's going to be kind
of a "Hunger Games" kind
of thing going on.
So please come up to the
mics and ask a question.
If people in the audience
don't ask questions,
I have some here, so we
can certainly do that.
I see someone walking
up right there.
Why don't we start
with that one?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The mic
is too tall for me.
So following up to the question
about architecture components,
I remember Dianne posting
online, saying like, you know,
look, we gave you activity, we
gave you a content provider,
we gave you all these things.
That's the agnostic platform.
You can do whatever
you want with it.
Like, we're not going to
impose any choices on you.
I'm sure there are other
people on the Android team
who agreed with her.
I wonder what Dianne
and those other people
might think about
architecture components.
Is this like a perversion of
like their vision of Android?
Or is this like--
DIANNE HACKBORN: All wrong.
AUDIENCE: Or is
this something that
like, OK, well, I understand
why some people might need it.
But if you want to do things
weirdly, you can do that.
Like, was there a debate
about architecture components?
DIANNE HACKBORN: So
the answer to that
is that basically all still
holds true as far as the core
platform is concerned.
So you can think it like--
and when I say it, I meant
it as a framework team,
it's really the core platform.
This is a step that's
shipped on the device
that like defines what you
can do with the device.
And we want to keep
that still generic,
not enforcing any particular
model on applications where
it doesn't make
sense, because we
want to have a lot of
flexibility for applications
to do new things and
iterate on things
and all that kind of stuff.
The architecture components
are basically a layer on top
that, you know,
it's very different
because it's in the
support library.
So it can actually evolve very
rapidly with the applications.
It can change and
break because it's not
going to break the applications
when those changes happen.
So we're basically
putting a new layer
on top of the platform that
gives our very strong position
on how we think applications
should be developed,
which will probably actually
evolve very much over time
as the world changes.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
And let's face it, every
few years [INAUDIBLE]
has decided there's a new and
better way of architecturing
things.
We had MVC then MVP the MVVC.
We discovered MVI the
other day on Twitter,
I have no idea what it is.
I think you're just making
that up at this point.
So yeah, I'm sure
in a few years,
it will have evolved
to something else.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: I also
want to tell a funny story
about that post
that you referred to
of Dianne's, because we were
talking about it backstage
like three minutes ago
or a few minutes ago.
How many people here have
read that post of Dianne's?
See, I told you.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Wow.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: So so many
people have read that post.
And I remember you posted it and
then it got like 125 comments.
And I remember I walked
back to Dianne's office
and I said, Dianne, do we
need to have an opinion?
And she said, I think
we might need to.
So it's been great
to get the feedback
and it really helped us
figure out how to evolve.
CHET HAASE: Thanks
How about over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
A question on media
formats, codex.
Is there anything beyond
the HDR VP9 that's new in P
that you can talk about?
ROMAIN GUY: So something--
CHET HAASE: Something, but can
you come closer to the mic,
maybe, it's really the
acoustics are very difficult.
AURASH MAHBOD: There we go.
CHET HAASE: Great.
AUDIENCE: Audio video
codex, new formats in P
that you can talk about
beyond the VP9 HDR support?
DAVE BURKE: New codex in
P. Uh, I remember in O, we
added a bunch of Bluetooth
codex like AAC and LDAC
to go beyond SBC.
I don't think we added any
codex in P. I'm looking down,
phone a friend.
This is when I call
to the adware team.
Yeah, everyone's
shaking their head.
I don't think we added any
new codex in P. I think.
CHET HAASE: Our consensus is no.
[LAUGHTER]
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
First of all, I just
wanted to thank you
all for all your hard work.
ROMAIN GUY: Thank them.
AUDIENCE: And
everyone, actually.
So it's been a great
I/O. And I think
you've made a lot
of progress in just
listening to the community,
so it's been awesome.
My question is going to be
about testing, which I know
it's going to really shocker.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ROMAIN GUY: Chet, that's
a question for you.
CHET HAASE: Somehow I knew that.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
question obviously for Chet.
At the Android keynote two
days ago, Chet actually
had two slides on testing.
One was something about
fluent assertions,
the other had a picture of
a drink with a straw in it.
It was about the ability
to mock final static things
in the Android framework.
And then Romain made
an awesome comment.
He's like, Chet looks confused.
You know, and actually
I was also confused.
I don't know why you would
want to kind of not maybe give
that ability, but
highlight it as one
of the important things
in testing, because later
in the testing talk-- and we
actually talked about the fact
that that's kind of undesirable.
We don't want to
have people do that.
So could we get
some comment on what
is our official stance
on actually using
that very powerful and
dangerous approach to testing?
CHET HAASE: What's your opinion?
So--
AUDIENCE: I don't
know, I don't have on.
CHET HAASE: --official stance
is probably a little strong,
but I would say there
are probably more--
there are more better
approaches to testing,
such as the other stuff
that I talked about,
the ATSL stuff that's
in Jetpack now,
Espresso, testing frameworks
that actually do things
correctly.
However, you heard from
the audiences response
to the ability to mock the
framework that sometimes
developers need-- for
whatever purpose--
the ability to do that.
And the framework is
really about providing
the capabilities that you need
for your particular situation.
So by providing the ability
to mock the framework,
specific methods more
easily, we're saying here
is a facility if
it's important to you
and necessary for
what you're doing.
It may not be the right
general approach overall,
but if it's a piece that
people feel they need,
there's a bit of
plumbing for you.
I don't know if anybody else
had a different take on this.
Does that help?
DIANNE HACKBORN: I mean, I
guess I could add a little bit.
There's, philosophically, like
not having finals and stats
and stuff is fine.
You know, the issue is
within the platform,
we have those in the APIs.
AUDIENCE: And that's for
a good reason, actually.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Right.
But that means
that if you do want
to mock something in
the platform anywhere,
you need to be able to do that.
And so we had, actually,
a discussion about
like getting these into Mockito
and there was like, no, no, no.
This is wrong.
You shouldn't do this.
But we kind of
reached the agreement
that well in this case,
it actually makes sense.
This is like something
we need to do.
So that's why it happened.
AUDIENCE: So it was kind of
like the framework developers,
almost.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Well not
for framework developers,
but for anyone who's writing
tests where they want
to mock out framework APIs.
AUDIENCE: OK, that makes--
DIANNE HACKBORN: Like you
have a context that you
get a WindowManager
from and you want
to mark out the
WindowManager object
to see if the correct
calls happen on it.
AUDIENCE: All
right, thanks a lot.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What's
your current thinking
around Android tablets?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: They like them.
AUDIENCE: Do you still see it
as a device type within the base
platform, or are you
like winding it down
and chucking it over the--
CHET HAASE: I'm missing--
if you can get closer
to the mic, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Like, do you
still see it as a base part
to the platform or have you
chucked it to Chrome OS guys?
Because it's kind of like
we're getting mixed signals
and it's like with Chrome OS
they don't support Android,
but they don't
put Android first.
They have a
different system UIs,
so it's like is
there going to be
a tablet version of the new P
overview swipe thingy whatever,
I guess?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: So from a
platform perspective,
we support tablets.
You know, we have
some [INAUDIBLE]
and we still support tablets.
From a Google Pixel perspective,
which is a product team,
they've been focused on
the crossover form factor.
So tablets crossing over with
laptops, so the Pixelbook,
for example.
And once you have
a hard keyboard,
Chrome OS is a really
nice operating system.
And so what they've done
is they've brought Chrome--
as you know-- brought Android
apps running within Chrome OS.
And to us purists
on the Android team,
it's actually a nice
thing, because it's
the same apps that
run on a Chromebook
with Android as on a tablet.
And so in so far as it's helping
Android's ecosystem have better
large screen landscape-sized--
in this case-- apps,
it's all helping.
Like, it helps tablets too.
But yeah, that's
sort of the status.
As far as the platform's
concerned, we support tablets.
There's a lot of
Android tablets.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Mm-hmm.
CHET HAASE: You look like you're
not done with your question.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
Or you're not happy
with my answer.
AUDIENCE: It just seems
Chromebooks are still
focused on web first.
Yes they support Android,
but they're not like--
they don't put it first.
So it's like what's the story
from the developer side?
AKA, I bought Pixel C, you
don't support it anymore,
but it's like
should we be buying
Chromebooks and detachable
Chromebooks to develop on or--
DAVE BURKE: I mean, you
should buy whatever device you
think is good for you to buy.
I use a Pixelbook, by the way.
I love it, I think it's good.
And I run Android apps on it.
That's me personally.
But I think everyone should
pick whatever product they want.
From our perspective, you know
as a platform operating system
provider, it's important
that Android supports tablets
and has good tablet apps.
And that's what we focus on.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I went to one
of those sessions, which
was the best practices for
kind of the current state
of Android.
And you guys went
over the current way
to do constraint layouts and
databases, but I was wondering,
you guys didn't
really go over what
you think we should be
doing for networking?
I know a few years
ago, you guys were
pushing Volley really hard.
But now, I feel like there's
Volley and Retrofit and 15
other libraries.
And I know it kind of depends
on what your use case is,
but if you were going to say
for someone starting off,
what would you recommend for
the networking manager for us
to use in an Android app?
CHET HAASE: Recommend for what?
AUDIENCE: For networking.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: Networking.
AUDIENCE: Like making
network requests,
just a regular GET request.
CHET HAASE: Someone in the
peanut gallery says Retrofit.
You want to have a vote on that?
Yes?
OK?
Yeah, Volley was the right thing
for some things at the time.
I think that there are probably
other more evolved libraries
out there that might
be the right solution.
And I think all libraries
do non-overlapping things.
So I don't think
there's an exact match.
But they said Retrofit.
I certainly hear a lot of
good things about that.
[CHEERING]
Like, one of the--
there we go!
One of the things
that we're doing,
co-incidental with the
architecture components
but it's not necessarily
the same thing,
is that when there's
a good library
out there that we
didn't happen to build,
we're happy to recommend it.
That goes for Retrofit,
it goes for things
like Picasso for image
loading, Glide as well.
Whatever the thing is,
if that's a good library,
why should we
reinvent that thing?
In this case--
[STRONG WIND BLOWING]
[LAUGHTER]
All right, maybe
not Retrofit then.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Are we done?
ROMAIN GUY: Did you plan that?
CHET HAASE: All right.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: I can add
we've been walking around
and several people
I have talked with
have asked if we can
recommend more libraries,
specifically outside of
Google, the ones created
by the community, which
that we think work best.
And so I think that's
been a great question
and great advice.
It's always been our
intention with Jetpack
to have an opinion about the
best way to do development,
because several of you
have said that saves time.
You don't have to look at
a bunch of things or six,
as [INAUDIBLE] always tells me.
So I think it's
been great feedback.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: Is this close enough?
Yeah, it is.
So a lot of the examples we've
seen for code during I/O--
not close enough-- a
lot of the examples
we've seen for code during
I/O have been Kotlin code.
And I guess a question
that I kind of have is
what's the long-term
things that developers
can expect if they have a large
code base that's still in Java?
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: Let
me make sure I have that.
The question was what
should developers
expect if they have a code base
in Java programming language?
AUDIENCE: Right, like
long-term support--
STEPH CUTHBERTSON:
Yeah, I can take that.
So when we invested
in Kotlin, we
knew that was going to be an
investment for the long-term.
So we're completely
committed to the language.
We also knew when we
invested in Kotlin that day,
whenever it was, May 17, that
it meant that we were doubling
down on all of our languages.
And a lot of you have
also said that we
needed to do more to support
the existing languages we had.
So the way we saw it was we're
not choosing a new language,
we're investing in
all of our languages.
And in fact, you can see that
in C++ we've launched ndk-build,
CMake, we've significantly
improved the ndk,
we launched the new C++ profiler
while we hear the toolchain
in the Java programming language
because we added Java 8--
java.time is my
personal favorite.
And you should expect
to see us continue
to invest in our languages.
It's really important with
such a large ecosystem
to support that
ecosystem where it is.
At the same time, we've seen a
tremendous interest in Kotlin.
I think we talked about
some of the statistics,
and so like 28 of the top 100
apps, 35% of pro-developers.
It's had 6x growth in one year.
So if you haven't
looked at the language,
we do think it's a good
idea to take a look.
But hopefully, that helps
answer that question.
ROMAIN GUY: And to
us, you're saying
that's why it took us so long
to support another language,
because the community
has been asking
for different languages
over the years
and it's been 10 years
since Android launched.
We wanted to make sure
that whichever one
we picked we would support
truly and correctly,
without dropping the other one.
So we took out time, we think
we made the right choice,
and we're going to keep
working on all three languages
that we support today.
CHET HAASE: I can tell that
Xav wants to say something,
so I'm going to toss a
tools question over to him.
So are there any plans
for tools for build
speed profiling and optimizing?
I think the context
of the question
was not can you make
the build faster,
but if they see their build
is taking a long time,
are there tools,
are there approaches
that they can take to find out
what it is that's taking time
so that they can optimize it?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
Yeah, we see a lot of developers
having a lot of issues not
being able to make
their build faster,
and we definitely
want to help there.
There's already a lot of
resources that you can use.
Gradle has build scans
that allow you to really
get a lot of insight
into your build,
so you can definitely use that.
But we realize that
having something
integrated into studio
would be extremely useful,
so it's definitely
something we're considering.
CHET HAASE: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I downloaded
the Android P beta
and I'm having a
good time on it.
But my question is why
did ya'll remove the Clear
All on the Overview tab?
DAVE BURKE: Yes.
I asked that exact
question to the team
about five or six weeks ago.
And they sighed at me like, ugh.
And-- oh, are they over there?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the team's here.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE BURKE: Hey.
Hey team.
Hey team, I told you so.
AUDIENCE: So there
are two answers.
One is Android is managing
the memory as well as you can.
You don't need to swipe
things away for Android
to be able to reclaim
that memory in order
to be able to run other things.
The second answer is
yeah, sorry about that.
We're looking at
bringing it back.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE BURKE: I can
tell you I have
a build that's after
beta one on my phone,
and I can proudly
tell you there's
a Clear All button on it.
So it's coming back.
[CHEERING]
AUDIENCE: Weeks.
DAVE BURKE: Weeks, yes.
AUDIENCE: So in 2014, I
was at the Moscone Center
and I asked you guys a
question if you're going
to keep maintaining Eclipse.
And I'm really glad
that you were not.
I'm 100% on the Android
Studio wagon now.
I still worry about build times,
which was one of the questions
that I had then.
But my question to you
guys is, what are the warts
that you wish you could
redo from Android 1.0?
So if you could do Android 1.0
again, what would you change?
ROMAIN GUY: Oh, so many things.
[LAUGHTER]
The UI docket, the
graphics pipeline.
DAVE BURKE: Ouch.
ROMAIN GUY: I did some of that.
CHET HAASE: I know.
DIANNE HACKBORN: To not let
applications write settings.
CHET HAASE: I've often
thought that designing APIs is
building future regret.
I have never yet created an
API that I haven't regretted
something about in the future.
I believe that they ran
really fast-- they, I
was not there at the
time-- at the time.
And therefore, they were
able to get it out the door
and now we have time to actually
fix some of those warts.
What we can't do is remove
methods and break applications.
So we would certainly--
we have been improving things,
hopefully, and introducing
new facilities to
make things better,
but we can't actually get
rid of some of the things
that we regret because we don't
want to break the apps that
are depending on it.
So there is that
little bit of stuff
that we can't quite totally fix,
but we can improve other things
along the way.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah,
there's a number of things
that you find just like
we did 10 years ago.
And today, you're like, oh
my gosh, that is not scaling.
One of the ones that really
stands out is a broadcast.
Our initial decision
to say, by default,
when you send the
broadcast, it just goes
to any manifest receiver
that wants to receive it,
was a really bad decision.
And we've learned this
over the last few years
as we've seen on devices,
more and more applications
waking up when just
random things happening.
So we have been going through
this really painful process
with the background restrictions
and all that kind of stuff,
to try to get control
of that again.
DAVE BURKE: Is a good
time to file a bug report?
Because I've noticed
on my bill that when
I change between cell and Wi-Fi,
it's slowing down a little bit.
There's a little
bit of jank, which
I know is broadcast because
of the network change.
So Tim Murray, we've
got to fix that bug.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVE BURKE: Just having
a team one-on-one here.
AURASH MAHBOD: I'd
also add multi APK.
I kind of wish we had moved
to the app bundle style
optimization much earlier, like
the version code management,
the multi APK sharding
of the build time mode
imposed was just a lot of burden
to put on developers, like you.
And really excited that
we're removing that.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you guys hear me?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's deeply jarring
to see myself on that screen.
Hi.
So I've been doing Android
development for a while now
and I've really loved, you
know, over the past few I/Os
your guys' continued
investment in improving
tooling and supporting Kotlin
as a first-class language,
creating architecture
components.
This year at I/O,
we've also heard a lot
about Flutter,
which I understand
to be the kind of
cross-platform mobile SDK.
What do you all see in the
future of these two platforms
in terms of Google's investment?
Like, will one
supplant the other?
Do we all need to learn Dart?
What's the kind of five-year,
10-year view of that?
ROMAIN GUY: Right, so
Google is a big company.
We do a lot of things.
And as you can see
in the keynotes,
we explore the future.
We have tons of experiments.
Flutter is an exploration of
cross-platform development.
And we're excited because
the Android platform
is a place where both internal
teams and external teams
can build these kinds of
exploration and experiments.
They recently reached
beta and we're watching
and we're waiting for the
feedback from developers.
So yeah.
So we're excited that so much
is happening on the Android
platform.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So Android is now 10 years old.
And my question is, what
happens when the first developer
certificates start to expire?
CHET HAASE: When the-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: When the developer
certificates start to expire.
Do you have a mechanism
how to rotate the keys?
DAVE BURKE: Honestly,
I don't know.
Ben?
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: We'll
follow up after.
ROMAIN GUY: Let us know
when it happens and--
CHET HAASE: It's so
confidence-inspiring
that you guys-- never mind.
AUDIENCE: So yes, we are
obviously aware of this.
There were guidance back
then to use certificates
with long expirations,
like 30 years, which
from a security
best practice point
of view in retrospect,
another thing we probably
would do differently, better
support for key rotation.
So I think as you can
see in the USP code,
there is some work towards.
We've had some previous
experience with keysets
and now there's some more work
going on with new APK formats,
to support this
better in the future.
But it's still a
work in progress.
But something is
actively being worked on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: See,
I thought you were
going to say Android
is 10 now, what happens
when it turns into a teenager?
AURASH MAHBOD: Exactly.
CHET HAASE: I didn't want
to get into that one.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi guys.
Love your work.
RecyclerView is awesome.
Is that better?
RecyclerView is quite awesome.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Next question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But there's still
a few places in the platform
where you still need to
use base adapters like list
view, spinners, I think
there's some remote views that
might use it.
And--
CHET HAASE: Did you say slices?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Remote views,
yeah, and alert dialog.
I was just wondering if you
guys see that as a problem
or if you want to expand the
awesomeness of RecyclerView
to more places?
CHET HAASE: We are
certainly continuing
to work on RecyclerView,
to integrate more of what
people need in that component.
We don't want it to be a
kitchen sink of all things.
But it is certainly possible
to expand it into more use
cases that make sense for it.
I don't know if somebody
over there wants to take it?
Yeah, Adam.
AUDIENCE: Adam, UI
[INAUDIBLE] team.
So yeah, I think
that right now, one
of the biggest things
that kind of impedes
doing more of the
integration of RecyclerView
with some of the other
stuff in the framework
is exactly some of what Chet
was saying earlier, which
is that we can't do a
lot of really key changes
to some of the stuff
in the framework
there without breaking apps.
And RecyclerView is
a conscious effort
to break from some of those
existing APIs at the time.
So those aren't directly
one-to-one compatible.
So the stuff that's in
the framework right now
is still going to be there in
order to support the existing
app ecosystem.
But as we start
building new things,
I would expect to see
a lot more things built
on top of RecyclerView and other
Jetpack libraries like that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, can you hear me?
CHET HAASE: Closer is good.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So it looks like
there is a shift
towards single-activity
applications.
I was wondering to get some
background on the decisions
behind that and
maybe when you should
use a single-activity
application
versus a multi-activity
application?
CHET HAASE: Sure.
Did you hear that?
DIANNE HACKBORN:
Single-activity applications?
CHET HAASE: Single-activity
applications.
DIANNE HACKBORN: Yeah, this is--
I'm going to be the first
one to say, you know,
I don't have a strong
opinion either way.
But we definitely--
as the UI experience
has gotten more
sophisticated, it's
definitely clear that trying to
do seamless transitions and all
the things you want to
do between activities
doesn't really work very well.
And there's really no need--
you can think of activities
as basically--
the only place you
really need activities
is where you need main entry
points into your application,
right?
And so once you're
in the application,
whether you use
activities or fragments
or whatever else is kind of
irrelevant to the operating
system.
And we are leaning heavily on
fragments with all the new--
ROMAIN GUY: Navigation.
DIANNE HACKBORN: --navigation
and all that kind of stuff.
So that--
AUDIENCE: Are there any
memory management concerns
with activities?
Like having everything
in one activity?
DIANNE HACKBORN: Very
memory management?
I don't-- I'm not--
ROMAIN GUY: Profile your app?
DIANNE HACKBORN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Most of
the stuff that you're
building at that
point should be based
on some of the other
lifecycle events,
as things are coming and going,
as you're adding and removing
components from that
single container.
So the shutdown process
should be pretty similar.
Whether that's a
separate activity
or whether that's
another fragment.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
So this close enough, right?
OK.
CHET HAASE: Closer is better.
AUDIENCE: My question is about
the new digital well-being
in Android P?
So that was presented into
a keynote, this option
of actually defining
a limiter in time
for usage of particular apps.
So I was wondering-- because
they're already on the Play
Store for some years, some
apps that actually offer this
functionality--
did you guys base this
idea for those features
based on apps existing
or some research,
particularly some
psychology research
or something like that?
And is there any API that
third-party apps can just
use to contribute to
this digital well-being
idea in the operating system?
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
I mean, there's some great
apps on the Play Store.
Not just for this, but also
like Headspace and Calm
and sort of like a
bigger area of wellness.
What we've done is basically
created some low-level system
APIs, to do things that
you couldn't ordinarily
do in an app.
Like, we turned the
screen grayscale
or we disable app
launcher icons.
And we're also getting
hooks for app developers
to you have deep
links into their app,
to provide more information.
I haven't looked so
closely at the system APIs
to explain what all you can
do on top of them, but--
CHET HAASE: Dan?
DAVE BURKE: Dan?
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to throw in
if you want to help out with
the mission of digital wellness,
read up on the docs
for how notifications
and Do Not Disturb
mode work together.
So for example,
post notifications
with enough metadata
that the user can- there
are ways in Do Not
Disturb mode to say
oh, starred contacts get through
or certain apps get through.
You populate all
that information,
you give the user more ability
to safely enter the Do Not
Disturb modes that we provide,
knowing that they're not
going to miss important stuff.
Another way you can
work with Do Not Disturb
mode to help the user
manage their space is
to actually respect it, right?
So you can actually see what
the state of the device is.
And maybe this now
is not the right time
to try to get the
user's attention.
Right?
So there are ways that you
can already work with--
and those APIs are
already in the platform.
We've tuned them up a little
bit for P, but most of the stuff
has been in there since we
introduced Do Not Disturb
and then improved it
with channels in O.
So look at those APIs, put
those data on the notifications
to be able to
interoperate as best
you can with the Do Not Disturb
feature we've already got.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Just a follow up question.
If I'm interested in somehow
contributing with ideas
or working together
in this area,
it will be really cool if
I have a contact, some kind
of contract I can refer to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
about the Google Play services.
You jumped from
version 12 to 15.
What happened in between?
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: Hotels jump from
12 to 14 on their floors.
We just wanted to go one better.
I don't know the
story behind that.
Burgeoning Google services?
AURASH MAHBOD: I
didn't even know that.
I think the releases
just started overlapping.
We were testing a
bunch of experiments
and we decided that we
should just snowplow forward
to the latest release
for all users,
as opposed to maintaining
a bunch of experiments.
CHET HAASE: We're not good at--
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AURASH MAHBOD: Nothing
hidden in there.
CHET HAASE: It was three better.
Thanks.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is the sound good?
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So in our company, our goal
is to build an APK game
with the least size so
the users in third world
countries or
developing countries
don't have to spend more
data to download the APK.
So when last year you
guys released Kotlin,
we didn't share because
we read that Kotlin
will increase the APK size.
So we are trying to save even if
it's like 100K in the APK size.
So how are you going
to address that?
Is it still the same case?
If I try to move to Kotlin,
will my APK size increase?
STEPH CUTHBERTSON:
That's probably
a good question for Ben
and Brian [INAUDIBLE]
and Jeffrey van Gogh.
AUDIENCE: So
everyone the R8 team.
So R8 is our new shrinker.
And so we added
Kotlin-specific optimizations
to make the code smaller.
And we can actually do
quite a bit of things
that you couldn't do
in Java because you
have richer information
about your code
when you're coding in Kotlin.
We just started and R8
is still experimental,
but I encourage you
to take a look at R8
and see if it helps your case.
CHET HAASE: Can they
try out R8 right now?
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah, it's
an experimental feature
in Android Studio 3.2.
And there's docs on
how to opt into that.
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: So if
you'd like to try the new R8
compiler, just download
the latest preview
of Android Studio 3.2.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: First off, excellent
work on Android P, everyone.
As a follow-up question about
the Clear All notification,
why is the clock
on the wrong side?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Actually, the Start
side, because if you're in LTR,
everything flips over.
I don't know why I reached
for the microphone,
I didn't really want to--
No, this is-- I mean, this comes
from the display cut out stuff
that we see coming from OEMs.
We know we need to
distribute things
from one side of the
status bar to the other.
Some of us have
kind of always been
a little uncomfortable about
the asymmetry of the status bar.
Like the most neutral
state is everything
kind of on the right-hand
side, again the end-hand side.
So by moving the
clock over, not only
are we able to create
a consistent experience
across Android
devices irrespective
of whether they have an unbroken
top edge of the display panel,
but we can bring just a little
more balance to it overall.
CHET HAASE: I will
point out, too,
that if you prefer
it on the right side,
just take your phone
and turn it around.
Just 180 degrees, it works
perfectly every time.
AUDIENCE: But then the notch
would be on the bottom.
CHET HAASE: Well,
there's other issues.
I'm just saying, you know, it
depends on personal preference.
DAVE BURKE: I actually, as
a personal anecdote, when
we first moved the clock
over, I was like, oh,
what are we doing?
Why?
And then I think about
seven or eight days later, I
was like, somebody
came up to me and said,
are you still really
worried about the clock?
I'm like, no, it's fine.
So you get used to
it really quickly.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
We use features such
as Android Enter--
oh, OK.
Can you hear me?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So we use features such as
Android Enterprise and Safety
Net, but we have a lot of
customers with users in China.
And so we wanted
to know if there's
any guidance you can provide
for helping those users?
CHET HAASE: Ben?
BEN: I'm only getting
that because nobody knows.
For China, it's complicated.
I'm not going to--
Google has limited access there.
The servers, you
know, the whole issue.
So I don't have a
good answer for you
for what to do for China
other than it is something
that I think myself and a few
others here think an awful lot
about.
And the shortest answer
is it's complicated.
But we're not necessarily
giving up on it
because it is a problem
that we recognize.
There's an awful
lot of developers
that need to deal with that
market and we need to do more.
I'm not sure what that
means in terms of specifics,
but it is something
that's on my mind.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Probably time for a
couple more questions.
We are running out of time.
We'll get to as many as we can.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I noticed some
stylistic differences
between the AOSP Android
version and the version
on Pixels, which we
saw through I/O, namely
like rounded corners
versus square corners
and some font choices.
I was wondering what the
motivation behind that was?
AUDIENCE: Sure, I'll
take this one too.
They're small touches.
I mean you just
said yourself, we're
talking about fonts,
colors, rounded corners.
Functionally, we try
to keep those targets
as close as possible, because
if it's good for Pixel,
it's good for everybody.
But we do have--
we want to put a little Google
touch on things that we're
putting inside a box that's got
a nice big Google logo on it,
so we use the Google
typeface in activities.
And we've got some rounded
corners and different color
choices, just a
little bit of pain.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: With the whole Java
lawsuit and court ruling,
how's it affecting Android?
What should we expect?
DAVE BURKE: Oh no,
we're out of time.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPH CUTHBERTSON: Our focus is
on developing a great operating
system.
That continues to be our focus.
DAVE BURKE: Great answer.
OK, next question.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: I was told
to wrap this thing up.
I did have one more important
one from the Twitter thread
that I'll end this thing on.
I'm sorry we couldn't get
to all of your questions,
we would like to.
Someone did ask online,
when will Google officially
support Kotlin?
ROMAIN GUY: Last year?
CHET HAASE: May 17, 2017.
So I think that's it.
Thank you.
ROMAIN GUY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]